in heart of a soldier Pulitzer
prize-winning journalist and
best-selling author James Stewart tells
the story of Rick Rescorla the chief of
security for Morgan Stanley
mr. risk Orla helped over 2,000 of the
company's employees escaped the South
Tower on September 11th before becoming
a victim of its collapse this talk from
the much ado about books festival in
Jacksonville Florida is a half hour
thank you very much this is a really
unique event for me because I
specifically wanted to come to this
festival because it is based here in
Jacksonville as he mentioned both
because Jacksonville plays a role in
this book heart of a soldier and because
one of the main characters without him
this book would never have happened
lives in st. Augustine and that is Dan
Hill who at my request agreed to come up
on the podium as well so it's very
unusual me to be in a in a place that
plays a role in this story in which my
talk is also being heard by one of the
characters in the story and I hope it
will remind you as you hear a little
about it that this is a true story
nothing is fabricated in this even
though as in so many of the things I
have stumbled upon in my writing career
it may seem stranger than fiction it is
in fact a true story I'm sure all of you
remember exactly what you were doing on
September 11th 2001 when you heard about
the terrible tragedy in New York
I certainly will always remember that I
was in my apartment at 29th Street just
off 6th Avenue sixth Avenue used to have
a clear view to the south of the Twin
Towers in fact when visitors were there
and they wanted to get their bearings I
always said we'll just look down 6th
Avenue if you see the World Trade Center
that's south one of the strangest things
that day was to to go out on the street
my neighbor is most of them strangers in
New York had poured out there was no
traffic moving and we stood in the
street and watched as the smoke first
poured from the towers and then watched
in horror as before our eyes first one
and then the second tower collapsed and
total strangers were embracing each
other or holding hands weeping together
and in that terrible moment had become
closer than any of
had and years of living there closely
together I have to tell you that as a
rider for the first time in my life that
day I was paralyzed I was working on a
story that was due for The New Yorker
and I sat down in front of my word
processor I thought well maybe if I go
back to work it will take my mind off of
all of this and I stared at the blank
screen and absolutely nothing happened
I've been blessed as a writer and never
having experienced writer's block but I
could find nothing to say that day I was
still in a state of paralysis the next
day when I got a call from the editor of
The New Yorker who who saved me from
this by asking if I would help on a
special issue of the New York or the
week after September 11th and since I
had written den of thieves and worked at
the Wall Street Journal I knew many
people in the Wall Street community who
had suffered devastating losses so I
went down to Ground Zero that week I
interviewed people from Cantor
Fitzgerald which suffered such terrible
losses and made some modest
contributions to that first week of
coverage I have to say as a reporter
that week it made me somewhat uneasy the
world's press corps had descended on
this tragic site and if none of you have
ever had the experience of seeing the
world's press corps in full hue and cry
let me warn you it is not a pretty sight
and I had this uneasy feeling that I was
only one step away from an ambulance
chaser that people who were suffering
terribly in the midst of tragedy were
suddenly simply being reduced to two and
three paragraph stories for consumption
of the general public but I had to
remind myself several times that this is
my job that what whatever happens I'm
there to try to tell stories to other
people little though I realize that in
those first hours of paralysis and the
shock of dealing with this enormous
tragedy something that I realized would
change my life and everyone else is
probably forever little do I realized
that an incredible opportunity it was
also being placed at my feet it was an
opportunity that eventually turned into
the book part of a soldier and I have to
tell you that although books are very
much like children except they just
stayed longer than nine months and in
most cases
and you love them all and you try to
love them all equally
I have to admit that of everything I've
done this is the closest to my heart and
the work that means the most to me
personally I first heard of rick ross
choral of that first week when I was
down on Wall Street Morgan Stanley the
big investment firm was the single
largest employer in the World Trade
Center with 3700 people working there
and yet this is better I hope they
employed 3,700 people in the World Trade
Center the largest employer in the
center and yet early indications
suggested that there were only five or
six casualties among employees at Morgan
Stanley even though they occupied almost
40 floors in the first Tower to collapse
the floors above them had suffered
devastating losses even some of the
floors below them firms had suffered
devastating losses and there's an old
saying in journalism that sometimes the
story is the dog that doesn't bark
it's what doesn't happen that piques
your curiosity not what does and I
remember thinking at the time
I wonder how so many people from Morgan
Stanley got out I wonder what explains
that but in those early weeks nobody was
writing that kind of story with massive
amounts of loss and then a friend of
mine mentioned Rick was corrala to me
and said believe it or not there is one
person who was responsible for the fact
that Morgan Stanley had suffered so few
losses he had gotten thousands of people
he was the director of security there
he'd gotten thousands of people out and
then he went back into the tower and was
never seen again and hearing that fact
just hearing that little bit made a
profound impression on me because I
immediately realized that this was
someone who after saving so many people
he could have left the World Trade
Center then and there and had been
acclaimed as a hero and had been alive
today and yet for some reason he went
back and gave his life trying to save
others as much there was tremendous
amount of heroism that day I don't need
to tell you that but this was an example
of someone virtually unique of
many stories I have heard who was under
no obligation to go back into those
towers it was not part of his job
description to plunge into that inferno
and yet he did this this this just
trigger two thoughts in my mind first of
all in my experience that the best
stories I've written have always begun
as something of a mystery a question
such as why would someone behave in a
certain way how did something happen
something that is very difficult to
understand and in this case I wanted to
know what kind of person was this and
why would he make the choice to risk his
own life and to face almost certain
death to save others
and secondly I recognize this in its
broad outlines as one of the most
elemental stories that has been told
throughout human history and that is the
story of an individual human being who
chooses to give up their own life for
others in other words in its very
essence it suggests that there are
causes in life that are more important
than our own individual survival and
that has been at the heart of many of
the great stories that have been told
throughout mankind now I'm an admirer of
the work of Tom Wolfe his excellent
nonfiction writer and has also become an
excellent fiction writer I teach a
course in writing at Columbia and Tom
Wolfe came one year to speak to my
students for which I was very grateful
he also he made the point in my class
and he has also written a famous essay
in Harper's in which he criticized many
fiction writers for always looking more
inward looking at the smaller stories
and failing to capture the sweep of
modern history and society in the way
it's a great novelist of the past had
danzo la Balzac Dickens trollop he said
that we had a generation of writers who
were not facing these kinds of stories
for whatever reason and he challenged
nonfiction writers in his essay in my
class to step into this bridge to find
the true stories in our world today that
capture the broad sweep of human
experience
and in doing so to convey in the
nonfiction format all of the truths and
the power that fiction writers has often
have often given us but I have to tell
you as a nonfiction writer the
opportunity to accept that challenge the
opportunities when you are dealing with
fact are very unusual but even when I
first heard this story I had a glimmer
of an idea that perhaps in this the
greatest tragedy of my lifetime and in
the life of Rick was corrala there was
possibly the opportunity to tell that
kind of story I began my reporting um by
getting into contact with Rick's widow
Susan I had gotten her name from someone
at Morgan Stanley Morgan Stanley oddly
enough did not really want me to pursue
this story they did not want anyone to
focus the tragedy and their role in it
particularly but they gave me the name
of students Widow and I called her in
New Jersey and this was a difficult call
to make as you can imagine someone had
just lost her husband I had learned that
they had only been married for three
years but Susan agreed that she would
talk to me if I came out on the train
now I have to say that I've often been
in a reporting situation where someone
weeps across as an investigative
reporter often writing about
white-collar crime I had to say in many
cases they've been weeping because they
were arrested or they got caught but I
consider myself relatively stoic and you
know I've been able to get through these
situations so I arrived Susan met me at
the Train and she was very lovely very
gracious she seemed very calm under the
circumstance as we went to the home that
she had shared with Rick she showed me
many pictures many things related to him
we sat down and started to talk and
predictably within five minutes Susan
was weeping the twist in the story was
that in seven minutes I was weeping as
well and we were basically just handing
the box of Kleenexes back and forth
several hours later I was on the train
back to New York I looked down in my
notebook and I saw I had written about
two sentences and I realized I'm never
gonna be able to make a story out of the
it had been a very emotional experience
but nonetheless a very valuable one
because I think we did become very close
in those first meetings and I think two
seasons immense credit she eventually
shared virtually everything about her
life and her amazing relationship with
Rick the book opens with the scene where
Susan having been twice divorced was
walking her dog and a very mysterious
stranger passed by he was running in his
bare feet and to this day Susan doesn't
know why she did it but she spoke out
and said why are you running in your
bare feet and it turned out it was Rick
and he was writing a play about his
experience in Africa where he had
observed the natives in Africa off and
running in their bare feet and he wanted
to see what it felt like and naturally
that was a pretty intriguing story and
it launched a really remarkably intense
wonderful late-in-life romance between
Rick and Susan some of you you know may
be roughly my age may have read the
famous Newsweek story which said that
single women over 40 the odds of meeting
a man are lower than being struck by
lightning let me tell you that Rick and
Susan prove that that isn't that isn't
true late in the reporting I ended up
turning this into a story for The New
Yorker that was really focused on the
relationship between Rick and Susan but
rather late am i reporting for this
story Susan also mentioned that Rick had
had this amazingly close best friend
named Dan Hill and I spoke to Dan on the
phone to find out some more information
about Rick and he made an impression on
me even on the phone he lived in st.
Augustine and I remember saying several
times to Dan I said Dan you've really
had a pretty remarkable life it was
quite modest and he didn't really seem
to agree with that and but he appeared
as a character in the story although not
as a major character in the story after
the story came out he was coming up to
New York to see Susan and we were still
talking so we agreed to have dinner in
Manhattan
and I thought probably I had told this
story as much as it needed to be told
but I met Dan for dinner and Dan told me
a few more stories and I don't think
I've ever told him this but at the end
of that meal I'd hadn't even brought a
notebook I didn't write anything down
but I the first thing the next morning I
called my editor at Simon & Schuster and
I said this has got to be a book you
have got to let me turn this into a book
and very shortly after that I arranged
to come spend a weekend with Dan his
wife Patricia who is also here here
today to hear more of these amazing
stories of the life and Rickon Dan that
had preceded citizens having that met
her husband including many stories I
don't think Susan herself even knew so I
landed here in in Jacksonville dan met
me at the airport and he had insisted
that I spend the weekend with with him
and his wife at their home
I haven't actually told dan this but
from past experience as a reporter I've
learned that it's sometimes it's very
risky to agree to spend the weekend with
someone's home you never quite know what
you're getting into I had a good feeling
based on my early meetings with Dan but
you never know so we pulled up to his
house and we went inside and one of the
first things I noticed is he was showing
me around the house was his quite
extensive gun collection which I'll
admit made me slightly nervous but I
think as a reporter you you learn to
trust certain instincts and within 5 or
10 minutes I I felt like part of the
family
really and ended up having a wonderful
weekend with Dan one of the stories that
he told me which was completely
unexpected was how he had met Ric when
he was working an amazing capacity and
as an undercover operative in the Congo
in 1960 and Ric was fighting in Rhodesia
with the British police force there they
met after a rugby game became instant
close friends one of these almost
magical encounters in life that Ric
seemed to experience and Dan moved in
with Ric for a while
in the barracks in what was then
northern rhodesia one day one of the
natives came in to say that a lion was
taraf terrorizing a nearby village and
could Rick do anything to help so Rick
went to the hardware store whatever it
was the general store I got this
double-barreled shotgun hopped into the
back of the Land Rover with a guy and
off they'd want to find this blond and
you can read the whole story and all its
glory in the book but to make a long
story short the lion was there that some
down the line appeared Rick had this
plan where he was going to be in this
blind and they would fire as the as the
law and attacked a a goat that they had
tied up in the middle of a clearing
but his adrenaline was rushing and for
some reason before the lion had a chance
to attack the goat Rick just leaped out
into the clearing exposing himself to
the wine the wine shifted its attention
and made a massive spring towards Rick
he had two shots in the in the barrel
double-barreled gun and he fired and the
the lion was killed and fell at his feet
so he was a hero when he came back to
the village but there was a custom in
Africa at the time that the the claws
and the teeth of a lion protected you
that they had mystical powers would
protect you from life so Rick extracted
the teeth and the claws he distributed
them to thee they were blessed by the
witch doctor he distribute them to the
people in the village but he kept a two
of the teeth for himself and a shell
casing from that and today for the first
time Dan actually brought to me the
necklace with the shell casing and the
tooth of the law and now it has added
significance because Rick wore this this
tooth and the shell casing later in life
during his fighting in Vietnam and if
you don't believe that this tooth has a
mystical power read the account of his
exploits in Vietnam and
he somehow survived wearing this too
many years later after Rick and dad had
fought together in Vietnam brick had
moved to the United States become an
American citizen dan who converted to
Islam went to fight in Afghanistan
against the Soviet occupying forces and
to protect him Rick gave Dan the tooth
and the shell casing which to this day
dad wears and which is why we've seen it
for the first time today but of course I
couldn't help but notice that that meant
on September 11th Rick no longer was
wearing the lion's tooth I'm not the
kind of person who typically believes in
this kind of thing but those are the
facts and I leave it to you to draw your
own conclusion while I was here in
Florida Dan also he pulled out a
notebook and it was stained and water
stained and at handwriting
rather neat handwriting fortunately and
it was a diary of his time in Vietnam
many years before and he said you know I
haven't looked at this in years but you
might find this interesting
I didn't read it till I got back to New
York and as I started looking through it
again I had this incredible sense of an
opportunity gift that had presented to
me because it was a very vivid and
detailed immediate account of things
that had happened many years before and
from a writer's perspective I have to
say there is like no greater gift than
that kind of raw material you don't have
to rely so much on people's fading
memories over the years it was so vivid
it was so well written it really brought
if when you see the book I think you'll
see it brought those chapters and those
experiences with Rick to vivid life I
had another experience with a diary
because later in fact after the New York
historico mode I was again talking to
Susan for the book and she had mentioned
to me that in the weeks before September
11th Rick was having trouble sleeping
and so she suggested that that he got up
in the night and write down his thaw
it's that perhaps that would she had
read somewhere that that would help
clear his head and enable him to get
back to sleep so he did and she had
found the notebook after he died in
which waking up at night he had gone and
written down what was preoccupying him
and she had been very hesitant to turn
this over to me but one morning she
handed me the notebook and she said this
is the notebook and I immediately opened
it up and started reading and it was an
incredibly powerful experience I mean
these were Rick's own words in his
handwriting it was as though he was
speaking directly to me despite his
death on September 11th and amazingly
although they were written before
September 11th he couldn't actually have
known what was about to happen they were
filled with the most profound thoughts
about the nature of heroism the nature
of courage the obligations that one has
to one's one's fellow man and at the end
of the notebook he had been thinking of
writing an autobiography himself about
his remarkable life and he had written
some titles down that he was thinking of
using for the book and the first title
on the list was heart of a soldier and
the minute I saw that it was like a
chill went down my spine again I grabbed
the phone I called my editor in New York
and I said this has got to be the title
it was almost as though Rick himself he
did in fact name the book that would be
about him before he died now in this
material in the vivid recollections of
Susan the vivid recollections of down
the raw materials of the notebooks as
well as many others I interviewed every
surviving member of Rick's platoon in
Vietnam I interviewed people who had
worked with him he had an amazing life
in various turning points in world
history
I interviewed so many that people
remembered him who also knew Dan who
nooses and I realized at some point that
I finally I felt did have the raw
material to write a story that if not
entirely living up to it to Wolf's
charge would at least attempt to grapple
with some of those big themes
I had read last year in another book by
Jacques Barzun a book called
from dawn to decadence it's a social and
cultural history of the West from Middle
Ages to the president he had said that
the notion of the epoch no longer exists
in our culture because we live in such a
fragmented society that no one can agree
on any one cause it would be worth
giving one's life for the notion of the
epic the hero in classic literature was
someone who chooses duty over
self-interest and that Duty reflected
something some principle some value the
transcended divisions and in fact
unified people for the greater good I
was thinking about this just last week
when I went to a production in New York
of the Trojans which tells the very
familiar Greek story of the Trojan horse
coming into Troy Cassandra the the
character who warns of impending
disaster but no one will listen and then
the hero Aeneas who goes to Carthage and
falls in love with with Dido
but because the gods speak to him that
he has a greater distant he leaves the
woman he loves behind and sails to Italy
where he founds what becomes the Roman
Empire and I saw so many parallels not
obvious ones but clear ones to the story
of Rick dan and Susan one of the
fascinating parts of the book which I
won't repeat because you can read it but
is the way that van and Rick
investigated the security at the World
Trade Center before 1993 and saw the
weaknesses Dan when and consulted with
Rick again after the bombing in 1993 and
in a written report they warned of the
possibility of a plane crashing in to
those towers these were the warnings of
impending doom that no one would listen
to in New York and believe me I believe
the story of how the Port Authority
responded to security issues at the
World Trade Center still remains to be
told many questions have not been
answered but just like Cassandra these
were the warnings that went unheeded and
then at that pivotal moment with chaos
all around him and tried
looming Rick had to make that very
personal and in my view heroic decision
to leave behind the people he cared most
about the woman he loved and his best
friend just as Aeneas had to leave
behind Dido
and he went back into the tower in
pursuit of a cause I think we could
agree despite what bars on said was a
cause worth dying for
he saved 3,700 lives that day even
though he gave his own and I'm not one
also to necessarily believe in in
destiny and yet in seeing the facts of
this story and I hope you will ponder
this yourself I often was amazed at the
twists of fade the way that Rick somehow
escaped death in amazing circumstances
so that he was alive at that moment in
history were his particular brand of
courage and principled integrity was so
much needed I don't like to say what
this book means exactly because I think
like a novel that's something that that
readers need to to see for themselves
but it certainly caused me to reflect on
made many big issues I grew up in the in
the era of Vietnam War protests I don't
think I really ever understood the
Vietnam War from the point of view of
people who fought there until I got to
know Rick and Dan and I think I learned
a tremendous amount about the values of
the military the best values of the
military and some of the dangerous
values of the military
neither Rick nor Dan were simple minded
soldiers simply carrying out orders in
fact one of the amazing things about the
story I think is that in saving people
in the World Trade Center Ric defied the
orders of the Port Authority he'd keep
to keep people in those towers the Port
Authority was on the loudspeaker saying
stay at your desk and Rick countermanded
those orders and got all of his people
into the stairwell that is why so many
people escaped from Morgan Stanley but
he understood the qualities of military
leadership that at their best had been
so effectively cultivated
in the American military and I think
there are embedded in the story very
deep religious and spiritual overtones
that the events of the story can cannot
be explained simply by recourse to a
rational
entirely rational universe and this is
these values are very ecumenical and
non-sectarian in fact I don't think you
could find a cast of characters that
span the the world's major religions in
this way Dan himself converted from
Catholicism to Islam Rick had been
raised as an Anglican in England but had
come to embrace many Buddhist tenets and
philosophies and susan is a church-going
Episcopalian so are there many religious
threads that weave through the story and
yet I think you find that they're rude
the same common principles that in fact
unify the world's great religions not
divide them I like to say that this is
to me not in the end really a book about
September 11th it's something that
transcends September 11th and at least
for me in the face of that tragedy has
given me tremendous hope and inspiration
there was a scene in the story that I
found particularly moving one that Dan
described to me quite late in in the
interviewing process but just in April
of the year he died Rick was inducted
into the Officer Candidate Hall of Fame
at Fort Benning Georgia and Dan went to
see Rick received this great honor there
and it turned out was the last time they
were ever together but after a day of
you know ceremonies and camaraderie and
I have to say quite a bit of drinking
it's a
there's a fair amount of alcohol in this
story but a Rick turned to Dan and and
in his very typical way he always asked
questions he never gave orders he simply
asked questions and he turned to Dan and
said are we all that we could have
become this was late in their careers
dan had had a heart attack Rick was
suffering from prostate cancer at a time
when I'm sure most people would have
been entirely justified in resting and
retiring and simply settling down to
enjoy their remaining days
Rick was still trying to become more
than he had become he was questioning
whether they had achieved all that a
human being could achieve in their
remarkable laws and all I can say is
that on September 11th he did become all
that he could and that's something I try
to think about every day am i all that I
could have become can I do more with the
qualities that have been to study state
upon me and that to me in the end is the
message I take from Rick and one that I
hope will inspire many other readers as
well thank you
James Stewart is author Oh den of
thieves bloodsport and his latest heart
of a soldier it's published by Simon &
Schuster on the web at Simon Says
dot-com